먼저, 상태 준비, 유니터리 gate, 측정은 단일 gate나 단일 qubit 측정 또는 상태 준비로 직접 수행되는 게 아니라,
소위 가젯(gadget)으로 수행돼요. 이 가젯은 각각 여러 qubit과 여러 연산을 포함할 수 있어요.
이 다이어그램에서는 이걸 보라색 박스로 표시했어요.
이 보라색 박스들은 우리가 구현하려는 상태 준비나 gate로 레이블이 붙은 작은 circuit이나 연산이라고 생각하면 돼요.
두 번째로, 오류 정정 코드를 사용해서 qubit을 보호해야 해요. 따라서 이 다른 가젯들을 연결하는 건 논리적 qubit 자체가 아니라, 가젯이
이 논리적 qubit을 인코딩하는 물리적 qubit에 작용해요. 여기서 중요한 점은 우리가 관심 있는 논리적 qubit은
절대 노출되지 않는다는 거예요. 즉, 이 논리적 qubit들은 우리가 사용하는 양자 오류 정정 코드의 보호 아래
평생을 보내게 돼요. 마지막으로, 계산 전반에 걸쳐 기회가 생길 때마다
인코딩된 qubit에 반복적으로 오류 정정을 수행해요. 이게 정말 중요해요.
직관적으로, 오류가 발생하면 qubit 상태에 무작위성이나 불확실성이 쌓이기 시작하고,
우리는 이 무작위성이나 엔트로피를 지속적으로 제거해야 해요. 그게 바로 오류 정정을 통해 이루어져요.
이 오류 정정 단계들을 논리적 냉장고나 열 펌프처럼 생각할 수 있어요.
논리적 qubit이 차갑게 유지되어 계산이 올바르게 작동할 수 있도록 해주는 거예요.
모든 선택이 이루어지면, 즉 모든 가젯과 코드의 선택, 그리고 특정 노이즈 모델을 가정하면,
우리가 스스로에게 물어볼 수 있는 근본적인 질문이 있어요. 과연 이게 실제로 도움이 되고 있냐는 거예요.
상황을 더 좋게 만들고 있는 건지, 아니면 더 나쁘게 만들고 있는 건지요? 노이즈가 너무 많으면
오히려 상황을 악화시킬 수 있어요. 오류 확률이 너무 높으면 9큐비트 Shor 코드가 상황을 악화시키는 것처럼요.
하지만 노이즈가 특정 임계값 아래라면, 이 모든 추가 작업이 효과를 낼 거예요. 강의 말미에 다룰 것처럼,
오류를 더 줄이는 길이 열려요. 이 부분에서는 방금 설명한 기본 구조를 가진 내결함성 양자
circuit에서의 오류 전파에 대해 다룰 거예요. 이건 매우 중요한 문제인데,
오류 전파를 제어하지 못하면 오류가 우리의 오류
정정 노력을 금방 압도해버려요. 하지만 오류 전파를 제어할 수 있다면, 코드가 오류를 충분히 높은 속도로 정정하여
계산이 작동할 수 있도록 훨씬 좋은 기회를 가질 수 있어요.
이 논의의 출발점은 2-qubit gate, 혹은 더 일반적으로 다중 qubit gate가
올바르게 작동하더라도 오류를 전파시킬 수 있다는 인식이에요.
예를 들어, CNOT gate를 생각해 봐요. CNOT gate가 수행되기 전에 제어 qubit에 X 오류가 발생한다고 가정해요.
X 오류는 X gate처럼 작동해요. 그래서
왼쪽의 circuit은 CNOT 이후 두 qubit 모두에 X 오류가 발생하는 오른쪽 circuit과 동일해요.
이게 오류 전파예요. 왼쪽에서 X 오류의 불운한 위치가 사실상 오른쪽에서 두 개의 X 오류로 바뀌는 거예요.
이걸 피할 방법은 없어요. CNOT gate를 사용하는 한, 항상 그 직전에 제어 qubit에 X 오류가 발생할 가능성이 있고,
그러면 이후에 두 개의 X 오류로 전파돼요. 하지만 볼 수 있듯이, 이로 인한 피해를 제한하는 조치를 취하면 괜찮아요.
그런데, CNOT 직전에 타겟 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생하는 경우도 같은 현상이 일어나요.
이건 앞서 다뤘고, 이 등식들은 곱셈을 직접 수행하거나 Qiskit을 사용해서 확인할 수 있어요.
결론은 두 경우 모두 여러 qubit에 걸쳐 상관된 오류가 발생한다는 거예요. 물론
CNOT gate 자체도 결함이 있을 수 있고, 이 역시 상관된
오류를 유발할 수 있어요. 게다가 이후의 2-qubit gate들이 이 오류를 더 전파시킬 수 있어요.
예를 들어, X 안정자 생성원을 측정할 때처럼 이런 식으로 CNOT gate가 세 개 있다면, 단일 오류가
금방 여러 qubit으로 전파될 수 있어요. 이게 하나의 코드 블록 내에서 발생한다면, 즉 함께 논리적 qubit을 인코딩하는
qubit 묶음에서 발생한다면, 우리가 선택한 오류 정정 코드는 아무 소용이 없어요.
코드는 저가중 오류를 정정하도록 설계되어 있지, 이런 고가중 오류를 정정하도록 설계된 게 아니니까요.
따라서 내결함성 양자 circuit에서 가젯과 오류 정정 단계를 생각할 때
이 점을 항상 염두에 두어야 해요. 내결함성 양자
circuit에서 오류 전파를 완화하는 가장 단순하게 알려진 방법은 gate를 횡단적으로 구현하는 거예요.
무슨 뜻인지 곧 설명할게요. 내결함성 circuit 구현 그림을 시각적 도구로 화면에 띄워둘게요.
여기서의 아이디어는 일부 양자 오류 정정 코드의 경우 특정 gate를 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있다는 거예요.
이건 각 연산이 각 코드 블록 내의 단일 qubit 위치에만 작용하는 연산들의 텐서 곱인 가젯을 사용해서 구현한다는 의미예요.
예시를 통해 설명하는 게 가장 쉬워요.
첫 번째이자 가장 단순한 예시는 Pauli gate의 횡단적 구현이에요.
아이디어는 circuit의 각 gate에 대한 가젯을 만드는 거예요. 모든 경우에서 이 가젯들은 텔레포테이션 circuit의 마지막에 있는 X와 Z gate에서처럼 코드 블록에 작용해요.
물론, 디코딩 후 Pauli gate를 적용하고 다시 인코딩하는 방식은 쓸 수 없어요.
그러면 논리적 qubit이 보호받지 못하는 상태가 되고, 재인코딩 결과로 코드 블록 내에서 오류가 전파될 수 있거든요.
다행히, 안정자 코드를 사용하는 한 그럴 필요가 없어요. 모든 안정자 코드는 Pauli
연산을 논리적 qubit에 직접 적용할 수 있거든요. 실제로 인코딩에 사용된 물리적 qubit에 Pauli gate의 텐서 곱으로
그렇게 할 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 이전 강의 말미에 나온 3x3 surface code를 생각해보면, 이 코드로 인코딩된 논리적 qubit에 X와 Z gate를 구현할 수 있어요.
여기 제시된 패턴대로 X와 Z gate를 항등 gate와 함께 텐서 결합하는 방식으로요.
이건 이 gate들의 횡단적 구현이에요.
예를 들어, 이전 강의 말미에 나온 3x3 surface code를 생각해보면, 이 코드로 인코딩된 논리적 qubit에 X와 Z gate를 구현할 수 있어요.
여기 제시된 패턴대로 X와 Z gate를 항등 gate와 함께 텐서 결합하면 되는데, 이 패턴들은
여기서 제시돼요. 이건 이 gate들의 횡단적 구현인데, 각각의 개별 gate 연산이
각 코드 블록 내의 단일 qubit 위치에만 작용하기 때문이에요.